[Music]
in the moral view of the world we see on
the one hand consciousness itself
consciously produce its object we see
that it neither encounters the object is
something alien to it nor does the
object come before it in an unconscious
manner on the contrary it proceeds in
every case in accordance with a
principle on the basis of which it
posits objective being it thus knows
this latter to be its own self or it
knows itself to be the active agent that
produces it it seems therefore to attain
here its peace and satisfaction for this
can only be found where it no longer
needs to go beyond its object because
this no longer goes beyond it on the
other hand however consciousness itself
really places the object outside itself
as a beyond of itself but this object
with an intrinsic being of its own as
equally posited as being not free from
self-consciousness but is existing in
the interest of and by means of it
paragraph 616 begins a new subsection of
this larger morality portion of the
massive spirit part of the work we're
actually getting close to the end of
spirit and getting ready to move into
the next section the next big part of
the work religion but we have a lot of
ground yet to cover this is the second
part of this morality section and we're
going to move through a number of
paragraphs and then get to the final
part of it now Hegel in the German just
uses one word as as the title for this
section two words of course if you want
to count the d the the the right in this
case but Miller translate this as
dissemble ins or duplicity we want to
read that or not as an exclusive or
either decembe lence or duplicity or
maybe both of them at the same time but
rather Miller is attempting to give us
two terms that he thinks will get across
the sense of this one German term Farish
day long and what is really going on in
this section why call it the section of
duplicity or decembe once well we've
been talking about the moral view of the
world the moral veldt on shaolong the
sort of total intuition of morality and
we saw in the previous section with all
of its paragraphs that although we often
take morality in the sense of day
ontological Duty based morality as
something relatively simple and
straightforward that we just have to
measure up to we find out that when we
examine the concept of it when we're
working the concept out there's actually
much more to the picture than we had
thought and it winds up with us being in
some contradictions or some to use the
term that Miller has been using
antitheses Gagan zetsu and we worked
through a number of them and arrived at
at a point and now Hegel is beginning
this section by a bit of you know
summary a bit of looking back to how
we've gotten to where we are and setting
out a problem that he's not going to
even attempt to resolve or even fully
elaborate here in this initial paragraph
but it is a double-sided nough so the
duplicity
you know in a way there's a play on
words here that that works out quite
well Duke listen II mean x' there is two
sides to something one of them is being
hidden one of them is is what is being
presented same thing with disks emblems
you put a disc semblance in front of
what is really the case and we want to
figure out well what really is the case
and we don't know which side were
actually going to pick so Hegel here
says in the moral view of the world in
the moral of Elton shower more alisha of
Elton showing we see on the one hand
consciousness itself can't consciously
produce its object and what do we mean
by consciousness consciously producing
its object well that is the achievement
that we've gotten to this far right we
have now seen that when it comes down to
duty this is not something that just
exists out there in a realm of you know
moral facts or things that we can just
take for granted that consciousness is
taking an active and you might even say
thoughtful role in making that be part
of the universe the moral belt on
showing the moral grasp or our view on
the world is in part a projection of
morality into the world by the conscious
agent and we can become conscious of
that and that gives us you know certain
implications about what we might do with
morality so he says it does it does not
encounter the object is something alien
to it something find something that
is estranged from it it recognizes
itself there and you know in this entire
paragraph I'd like to point out as a but
a little bit of a digression we see
Hegel setting out a kind of idealist
point of view and this is not something
that we talk about a lot and Hegel
himself doesn't bring up an awful lot
this notion of idealism but what is
idealism really involved one way to to
fundamentally understand it is that
being never truly exists solely on its
own totally isolated abstracted away
from some consciousness being always is
for some consciousness not necessarily
for our consciousness but for some
consciousness and that you know there's
more to it of course for Hegel idealism
is very practical you also have to
realize the idea in in V R click ID in
reality and actuality but there's
there's an another side to it which is
anything that you can conceive of as
totally estranged totally alien to
consciousness by virtue of being
conscious of it in thinking of it it's
no longer completely alien to it so
coming back to this he says the object
does not come before it in an
unconscious manner and this is part of
what embroiled us in these worries and
contradictions but but that drives the
dialectic further if we merely take duty
as something that we haven't just
imposed on us you know when somebody
says the tautology dooty is dooty is
dooty and they're trying to convey to us
that we should we should fulfill our
duties we should do what the duty
requires of us we are if you like
obligation we should fulfill our
obligations they're doing so in a
thoughtless in a unconscious one before
manner we're not doing that at this
point we that's what the you know end
point of working through this entire
previous section gave us we're now
conscious of what we're doing so he says
on the contrary
it what is the it consciousness or as
we're gonna see self-consciousness
proceeds in every case in accordance
with a principle on the basis of which
it posits objective being now we've seen
we've got an object
we've got objective being gegen stein
gig and stanley k right what is the
object the object is essentially our
duty isn't it the object can also change
a little bit insofar as there's a bit of
reflexivity here we might think about
the object is also being our own agency
our own activity but we're not we're not
quite there yet so we've got an object
that is absolutely essential to the
moral being in the world without some
sort of obligation or duty some sort of
in german flicked in latin debonair a or
debet um in greek some sort of day the
word we get de ontology from well we we
don't really have a moral view of the
world now notice here though Hegel is
saying that the object the duty is being
projected out by consciousness it
proceeds in every case in accordance
with the principle on the basis of which
it posits objective being but this
principle he says is something that
consciousness is is not just recognizing
but actively producing he says it knows
the latter objective being to be its own
self why it knows itself to be the
active agent that produces it the very
interesting idea there isn't it usually
we think of our own activity as
something that produces an object that
is different from us and which could be
dissociated from us this is the whole
basis of Marx later on talking about how
in in you know capitalism and also other
forms of Economic Development and
Exchange and and things like that
prior to you know some sort of
reconciliation and some far-off
communist arrangement he Marx talks
about the alienation of the worker from
the product of his or her work and
that's that's true right there is a
truth to that but in this part there is
a realization that I am producing that
that is something of me externalized out
there even imposing itself back upon me
as something that I can recognize this
is a very important moment in human
development in moral consciousness
development as well so he says it knows
itself to be the active agent that
produces it and Hegel says it seems here
to attain its peace and its satisfaction
for this can only be found where it no
longer needs to go beyond its object
because this no longer goes beyond it so
there's sort of a reconciliation between
self-consciousness and its object of
duty right peace ruh-huh rest is another
way of putting it it rests in this
conception of itself and its object and
satisfaction pathetic oh now that's not
the entirety of the story here Hegel
says he began this by saying on the one
hand here's the other hand the object is
also something that is there in a beyond
a yang Zeitz right on the other side so
he says on the other hand consciousness
itself really does place the object
outside itself as a beyond a beyond of
itself now that is a very important
phrase right there Hegel doesn't just
say eh beyond right think back to the
unhappy consciousness where this
dialectic of the beyond was being
brought out all the time and sort of
pushed back further and further and
further
now implicitly that was a beyond of the
consciousness or the self consciousness
that was back in the self consciousness
section
but here it's explicitly understood as a
beyond of the self-conscious subject so
we have an object there that is
projected far out outside of myself and
he says this object with now here's a
somewhat unhappy translation with an
intrinsic being of its own what is the
term that Hegel is actually using there
on and first examined up something that
is being or existing in itself Anzhi and
also for itself husak this is really you
know the sort of the gold standard for
Hegelian dialectic we've always got the
in itself the for itself and we bring
them together in the in and for itself
and that's really something that's going
to be ultimately just for a subject but
we're not at that point here so he says
this object with an intrinsic being of
its own is equally posited as being not
free from self-consciousness but
existing in the interest of and by means
of it so it's still even though it's
beyond self-consciousness it's still
within the scope of self-consciousness
it is existing by means of it and it is
existing in the interest or it's
connected to it in some way now how is
this going to play itself out that's
what we're gonna see in the paragraphs
to come and how are these two objects
related to each other are they different
objects or are they really the same
object
the moral worldview is therefore in fact
nothing other than the elaboration of
this fundamental contradiction in its
various aspects it is to employ here a
kachi an expression where it is most
appropriate a whole nest of thoughtless
contradictions the way in which
consciousness proceeds in this
development is to establish one moment
and pass directly from it to another
setting aside the first but now as soon
as it has set up the second moment it
also sets it aside again and really
makes the opposite moment the essential
one at the same time it is also aware of
its contradiction and shiftiness for it
passes from one moment immediately in
its relation to this very moment over to
its opposite because a moment has no
reality for it it posits at the very
same moment as real or what comes to the
same thing in order to assert one moment
as possessing being in itself it asserts
the opposite as the one that possesses
being in itself
in doing so it confesses that as a
matter of fact it is in earnest with
neither of them we must examine more
closely the moments of this insincere
shuffling
paragraph 617 is a good bit less
optimistic than the preceding paragraph
that started this new section of
dissemblers or duplicity and here Hegel
is telling us point-blank that the moral
worldview is involved in a whole as he's
taking this phrase from Conte nest of
thoughtless contradictions isn't that a
funny phrase we'll come back to that in
a moment but he begins by saying that
the moral view of the world is in fact
an elaboration and out-building of this
fundamental contradiction this this
contradiction or Vitas Brook at the very
ground or basis at the Grund he says of
what have what we've been studying this
says the moral worldview is nothing
other than this so the other thing he
adds to is in its various aspects and
that is going to be particularly
important because he's talking here
about these different moments in these
different moments are in fact the
aspects so the challenge is can we
actually get these all to come together
in some sort of harmony it seemed as if
at the very end of the last section that
we had managed to bring that off we'd
you know come to this higher synthetic
unity and now it seems as if he is
taking that away but it's because he is
not finished working through in this
contradiction so he says we have this
conscient expression being used where
it's most appropriate because oftentimes
Hegel thinks consol own expressions are
not most appropriate with him Conte
himself but it is a whole nest a not a a
mess of thoughtless contradictions that
have to be untangled so he says the way
in which consciousness proceeds in this
development and here he starts talking
about these moments right and I think
attending to the language is going to be
very important for on
standing what is going on here how do we
get this nest of thoughtless
contradictions why are they thoughtless
in this case so he says that
consciousness establishes a moment right
it establishes one moment and then
passes directly from it to another
setting aside the first it's not content
to stop linger and figure out what the
actual content is there to work through
the contradiction and it doesn't set up
the first moment and then set up the
second moment and examine the
contradiction between them
instead it's oscillating it's going from
one moment to another moment when he
says passes over to yubi gate it just
goes right over to the other one and it
does so in an immediate way there is no
thing that is explicitly mediating this
the other thing that he says that's very
interesting is in talking about setting
aside the first moment that it initially
began with and then passing over to the
second moment he uses this term of Haven
right the word that we get out hey bong
or whatever you want to translate it as
sublation sort of transcendence with
incorporation this key Hegelian term
he's using here in terms of setting it
aside so he says as soon as it is set up
this second moment we now have a
recursion we go back to the first moment
he says it sets it aside again and that
again behavin all right it behaved that
and he says it really makes the opposite
moment the essential one so in both
cases what it's doing is it's taking one
part of the bigger picture and making
that what is most essential and ignoring
the rest of it this is what we in other
areas or at other places in the
phenomenology will call one
sightedness anxiety kite right when
there's an attentiveness to one aspect
one moment but you're ignoring the rest
and that from a Hegelian perspective is
always going to be inherently
problematic so what does he tell us here
there's more to the story
consciousness is not just engaging in
this activity it's also aware of
engaging in this activity
he says it's aware of its contradiction
it's viateur stroke it is aware of its
as we're translating it here shiftiness
fish Dalit notice with this term fish
tellin that this is very very close to
the very title of this section fish that
long right Trishelle in' is the verb
fish telling is the noun composed from
that verb so shiftiness could also be
understood as duplicity or as decembe
Lentz it's becoming aware that it is
engaging in this and it says why is that
the case it passes from one moment
immediately in its relation to this very
moment over to the opposite and this
oscillating back and forth is not a good
way a happy way for consciousness to
exist just in the last paragraph we saw
that consciousness had attained a kind
of rest or peace of Roo together right
Rua actually in this case and it had
attained a satisfaction now it's already
lost this by being aware of what it's
doing so he says because a moment has no
reality for it it posits that very
moment as real let's pause on that for a
second precisely because a moment has no
reality for it it posits that moment as
real it tries to reintroduce it into the
picture into the dialectic and may
sense of it will it be successful in
doing so
or is this just making a mess out of
things this nest of contradictions says
because this happens or what comes to
the same thing in order to assert one
moment as possessing being in itself it
asserts the opposite one as the one that
possesses being in itself now notice
what Hegel says here in consciousnesses
own self-assessment in doing so it
confesses that as a matter of fact or in
the deed in the action it is in earnest
with neither of them it doesn't have
earnestly ting them in a honest
straightforward manner it's you could
say deceiving them although these
moments aren't really something that has
the subjectivity that could be deceived
but it is also deceiving itself and if
we bring in other consciousnesses it
would be deceiving those other
consciousnesses in the process in trying
to make things simpler or more
straightforward than they actually turn
out to be with respect to the moral view
of the world now the moral view of the
world can be understood as something
like a sort of perspective a static
perspective that sets these things out
and says okay here we go here's the
theory or another way of understanding
the moral view of the world is as an
activity as a process of what it is that
we're doing in regarding in the on
showing of the world in moralizing the
world and you might even say there's a
little bit meta Right moralizing
morality and trying to see it all the
way through past these contradictions so
he tells us at the end that we must
examine more clearly the moments and I
love this this the the great translation
here the moments of this insincere
shuffling right and the insincere here
is
findell then the word that we get you
know is it's a cognate swindle from
right you know there's some deception
going on here and somebody's trying to
pass something off and the shuffling is
just a translation of Beauvais going
movement so it's a little bit of
artistic license here on Miller's part
but I do love that that phrase before we
go on into that which is going to happen
in the subsequent paragraphs this
examination of the moments of this
insincere shuffling we should think
about well what are these moments what
is he talking about here
we haven't actually said what these
moments are just think back to what were
the moments in the early in the earlier
section as we were bringing it to a
close they were propositions
what were those propositions about they
were propositions about the reality or
reality of morality one proposition was
there is a moral consciousness the other
proposition is there is no moral reality
or actuality and so he's talking about
consciousness swinging back and forth
between these not having attained that
synthetic unity that was being discussed
in the last paragraph of the last
section
but as sort of reverting so how are we
going to get past that you might say he
he went to a certain point and then
backed up a little bit and now he's
coming at it through another way and
that's what we're doing in the rest of
this section
you